[Music]
um
here
we got him oh how did I win that whoa
oh my gosh that was like
getting put through the freaking meat
grinder
oh my God I'm like my hands are shaking
foreign
fish
oh pulterock yeah I know who that is
let's play
let's play the narrow con
[Music]
um I can take with a knight in sack the
pawn but I'm gonna take with the queen
okay clearly he knows this very well
I think if he castles him in a sack okay
Knight T5
okay we could go into a slightly better
end game probably
I'm Gonna Keep the Queens
[Music]
okay he's just a fast player I don't
think this is theory
could go C4
could go C5
yeah let's go C5
crappy wants to be six that's not good
hmm
okay let's throw this in
okay let's try to prevent B6 I need to
keep this Pawn alive so I can clamp on
his position
Knight T5
okay I'm trying to prevent B6
he plays it anyway
okay it takes to the night that's kind
of good for me to see
okay Queen C7 no Rook BC it doesn't work
let's go back to E5
I'm definitely better but I don't know
if I can win this we'll see
I'd have some tactics
yeah Bishop C6 Knight C6 Rook C6 Queen
takes Rook check
and I win The Exchange
I'm threatening
I don't know exactly what I'm
threatening I guess I'm threatening Rook
takes B6 but
um
it's a little bit messy
it's a little bit Lionel
can't figure out what I'm threatening
here
Bishop D7 Knight D7
a little bit worried about Bishop E8 I
guess I can just drop back to E4
keep my extra Pawn
with a decent position
could also push the pawn up to C4
at some point
we can now restart as I think
windy eight okay
[Music]
lots of
peeling options here I don't want to go
Rook B6
because then he goes Rook B6
57 Rook C2
Queen F3 is interesting also
okay let's try Queen F3
if okay F6 wait but now
okay
yeah I don't know what that was but I
guess he was hoping for a premium I mean
actually Knight C6 would still be
winning
I'm not hungover now
I'm just still getting over a little bit
of an illness
I did have a Guinness yesterday but I
don't think or I had half a Guinness
can you get hungover from half a
Guinness
no I
I just had a glass
Papua New Guinness
some of my worst hangovers have been
beer hangovers though
what's up Eric thank you for the sub
I remember okay I have a funny story but
I will share it
after this game
yeah Rook 81 everybody knows this okay
Bishop H6 I don't know
um when you think
I think my preferred non-hangover drink
is vodka soda probably the least thing
over inducing
thank you kiddo dizzy
foreign
here
's your G5 Queen D7 no no no no Bishop
G5
strip G5 Bishop E4 Bishop E4
Bishop F2 Queen F2 Queen G5 Bishop G5
get it
I don't want to take with the pawn but
I'm not sure
sick of the bishop
fee Maybe
I don't want to go 94.
yeah
wait shoot I've wondered before that's
not good
before ah maybe I have Queen F6 though
no I'm in trouble
I stumbled into a really really bad
position
is over if he plays accurately
yeah these CMS are pretty dangerous
[Music]
my only hope at this point is time
pressure
foreign
yeah he blundered
that was pathetic
it just resigns I don't know I never
understand when these players they they
navigate the uh incredibly tricky
tactical Waters perfectly and then they
blunder a one move tactic
like it's completely winning
if he goes to Rook F4 I think it's not
over completely but it's basically over
that's the Dania effect I guess it's
still not if he takes C7 and goes Bishop
D4 it's still not so clear
couldn't you capture the bishop but no
but I win The Rook that way no I can't
capture the bishop he has Queen C7
yeah Queen C7 Queen D4 is bad Queen F7
is best is the only good move
here he has Queen C7 and he has a bit a
bunch of pawns for The Rook
thank you in our 90.
so now this is only the only accurate
move
what's up Aquila
I was not invited gen moves
um
can I look at Knight D3 sure
difference I thought Knight D3 was the
same thing I didn't see the difference
oh I had maybe 95. but where did I go
wrong like I don't understand I was
better I thought
so the move here apparently is I'm just
supposed to take everything on e4
Essex is a channel
cookie
I thought I'd take C4 creates a
stronghold I just forgot that B4 wins
the plan
yeah I just it just blanked on this move
and now I'm busted
yeah a title player would have been me
No rookie 6 Queen E6 Desperado
no he's already in trouble here
okay I mean he was 20 2500 and I was 26
20. so
we're playing I think we're playing
Peter no Demetrius
foreign
all right let's see
what do we do here
I play this with black now I don't
remember what to do with white
foreign
I've had Greek food the last three days
so
I've gotten obsessed with this like
place here that has the best freaking
hero
yep
okay what I have the chat open I should
be focused
it's called El Greco
or no just Greco it's a chain
okay I'm getting outplayed
foreign
I thought maybe I can play F3 here
okay let's try it
what
oh my gosh she wants F4 really
who plays King h8 in that position okay
fine
I don't get it I don't know I'm just
trade freaking Queens
foreign
I think I'm over the over the hump here
96 yeah that's what I thought he would
do
okay Rook F7 is very tempting but then
King G8
he chases my Rook away
I don't know if I'll be able to convert
this
you know let's go C3 stopping
Knight D4
the issue is is Knights are really good
here
yeah this is not that good for me
I'm gonna go Bishop H3
rockefs
P6 I need a blunder
oh my gosh my phone rang and now I'm
100
yeah
been a little distracted and I made a
blunder
okay this is
virtually over
but I have some counter playing
um I can go Knight G6
Knight H5 now
F6 Maybe
why don't I see anything
ig6 is almost me
let's get Knight H7
try it
this time management has been Superior
to me to mine
Knight G8 is a dry thing
isn't that H5
no
nope I gotta make a draw sorry
oh he has Rook G3 Maybe
I'm actually better here
oh King F4 I should play that's a hard
mode though
yeah it's equal basically
now of course I should win this if I go
King F2 King G3
yeah that was
very bad blender
no Rook Cafe the square was defended
yeah that was dumb
yeah just wondering that F3
man it's so close to being made but
somehow he's just easily surviving
you can go Knight D7 apparently is
better
but
no Rook G3 loses but he saw that
King H4
that's a trap
okay H7 loses he he played perfectly
here
he didn't he didn't fall for a single
trick all right okay 25.50 we should be
able to win but he's on three out of
three
and he beat okay he beat a 2700 so
nothing special
okay D4 that's the annoying line
yep
people just know what to play these days
people know what to play these days
let's go G6 and Bishop G7
I'm gonna induce 95 and go back
the issue of these positions is they're
very hard to win
very hard to win
if white if white is solid of course
like if white does not do anything
stupid
it's going to be very hard to unbalance
the game
I don't really know why I played the
Caro against 2550.
um
so far he's playing pretty flawlessly
let's go B5
expand on the queen side Maybe
it's just playing
okay we gotta go H5 I can't allow H5
this is a classic title Tuesday game
actually
outmatched
[Music]
yeah them opening choice is a big
mistake
it's too easy to play for white
unfortunately
[Music]
okay
foreign
I have to be careful not to lose my
Bishop obviously
distinct possibility the way I'm playing
it
yeah he's gonna go Bishop D3
hey how do I save my Bishop there must
be a way
foreign
[Music]
yeah we got him that's a good
calculation there
yeah nice nice nice nice nice I didn't
Panic there
in in a worse end game
hey he blundered he blundered uh Rook
takes H4 and Rook h8
but rookie Che was a really good move
because if he had gone G3 then I would
have gotten the F3 Square so
it would have been playable thank you
Austin castles
okay big important win here to get us
into decent score
all right
pretty solid start yeah Rook h8 already
I'm better actually interestingly
because if he goes G3 he gives me the F3
Square
and then yeah this is lost
I was worried when he found F3 but G3 is
super strong
[Music]
yeah sharers thank you bar man thank you
the opening was it's not a terrible
choice I just think I need a line
against the Four Knights Caro that
unbalances the position because this is
so hard to play for a win
if white is accurate
there's just no Intrigue in the position
okay maybe Knight D7 is not the way to
go
yeah Queen G3 is the top move actually
interesting he played this very well
yeah rookie was a terrible move this was
this was just bad if he had gone A4 it's
plus minus
here Queen G4 is correct
yeah I mean I played pretty decently
okay we're going Microsoft okay I played
I drew him in the last title Tuesday
he's incredibly good
foreign
everywhere
and this is exactly what we had in the
last game too
russellimo
sorry let me get rid of this thing
[Music]
okay now I keep forgetting with the move
is
[Music]
okay I should have gone Queen A4 that's
why they played Queen A4
okay so I'm already worse
it's pretty encyclopedic knowledge of
the ocean
do you have pillowcase
[Music]
Maybe e5s
I don't know exactly what I'll do if he
takes I just hope he won't
[Music]
wow I actually got him to think that's
pretty big accomplishment goes Queen A4
Queen C4 make sensor I think then it
takes it
oh
okay Rook takes A2 I don't know what I
should do when we work a B1
[Music]
or should I play verification
Queen D1 oh that almost traps it clean
[Music]
okay
well that doesn't work as Rick B8 I
didn't see that
[Music]
foreign
ER
but it's not over
it's far from over
foreign
foreign
and I win
it
takes
the Knight C8 97 makes sense
foreign
there must be a mate here
I'm just gonna trust that there's a mate
it's mate nice very nice
and the patients have been running the
institution for a while now
soon there won't be any more institution
um let's go E4
foreign
McQueen
yeah this line is rare I'm not gonna go
for the main line with rookie one
yeah it takes takes okay white is
slightly better here
oh my God
it's like slightly better
okay
um he takes to the pawn which is
annoying
could go A4 Bishop A3
okay let's go rookie let's play Let's
play a neutral move
oh did I blunder Queen A5
I did didn't I oh
I suppose I have Queen B3
I forgot about Queen A5 that's why
you're supposed to play A4 actually
it all makes sense now okay it doesn't
play it
it all checks out let's go back
foreign
[Music]
okay now this looks really good for me
now
we could go 94 it could go Bishop F4 I
could go Queen F3 there's options
good go Bishop no I can't go Bishop A3
that drops a bishop
foreign
this move can't be bad
this move can't be bad
Knight A5 is very unconcerned about
what's going on on the king's side
um I don't know what to do here
oh Queen G3 Maybe
it should be five
it's playing very positionally
okay I want to keep the pieces on the
board
and then I want to go Bishop before
nice C4
could go Bishop F4 could threaten
checkmate
could go Queen h3h694
and he goes D5 I don't know
okay let's get the bishop out for now
and then we'll see
I don't know what's going on here
maybe H4 is worth playing
let's go H4 let's try to
press on his clock a little bit
[Music]
I want to go Knight H7 here sort of
okay he allows it I guess that H7 King
H7 HG and there's a dead end
hmm
yeah not easy
maybe back to F3 no gosh how is Knight
H7 not just mating
some black magic
I didn't like this move but I don't see
an alternative and I want to keep a Time
advantage
should pay for
you can go takes an H6 I can try to play
for mate there
[Music]
I don't know let's go here
takes takes Bishop C4 looks pretty good
we're here first
[Music]
oh no I've won to the pond oh that's a
rough one
foreign
oh man I just forgot it the bishop was
protecting it
[Music]
if this is a three plus zero game would
be over
oh it's not me
and I'm missing a lot of stuff right now
it doesn't work either wait maybe
it
does
um uncle peace is Bishop H6
all right Blended a perpetual
foreign
I'm lost
foreign
crap
no it's still a draw unbelievable it's
still it oh I'm winning
oh D7 oh D7 HG and King H3 only move
okay but this is insane King H3 wins
foreign
everything else either draws or loses
this is losing
Queen F4 is just game over
yeah King I should have seen that D7 HG
King H3
and there's no checks the Knight
dominates
it's just over I make a queen on the
next move
yeah I just panicked in time pressure
but okay at least I didn't now of course
I outplayed him but
then I blended a pawn which is
unnecessary
it says it's equal though I guess I I
overestimated this position in the first
place Mr Stu thanks
no I don't think that's findable and
with no time
it's it's about equal the entire game
even even after you blundered his Bishop
it's equal if he gives me a perpetual
yeah that was a game I had to win with
white that was a good pairing too he's
not like insanely strong
yeah this is the only chance
okay five out of six it's I'm still very
much in contention
at least now I'll get a manageable
opponent
oh man I got god with black
okay goes E4 interesting
what should we play
okay that's why Carl
yeah D3 okay he's gonna go for the
popular line
A4
to develop
um
okay here
I want to go Bishop B4
okay he allows I could take the pawn
here I wouldn't rule it out but I feel
like I'll get checkmated there so
I'm just gonna Castle
yeah I have a nice position
or maybe not
maybe I should go back to E7 I don't
know and go Knight C5
okay first I'm gonna go A5
okay I was gonna go here anyway
obviously I need to play for a win
I cannot afford to make another draw
foreign
trying to play quickly here I wanna I
wanna get him into time pressure I think
that's normally my best chance against
Kata
so I'm playing a little faster than
usual
[Music]
okay I've got a minute on the clock
which is good
[Music]
foreign
okay
yeah this is very equal
how do I unbalance the game
I'm gonna try to provoke him into
something
I'm gonna try to provoke him into an
exchange sec
it's very risky but I think it's my only
chance to win this game
yeah he's definitely thinking about it
he's thinking about it
okay he's got under a minute now which
is good
[Music]
okay he does go for it wait 94.
is Knight F7 it doesn't work that's
annoying
okay I think I have to go back
it's an unclear position
there's C5
okay back
let's go Rook a I don't know
I can also guard f8
um
hard to say let's go okay
I want to defend F7
[Music]
yeah but now I'm really stuck
[Music]
G4 I thought he would play
[Music]
I'm waiting all right
oh that was his idea
[Music]
because I
guess
that's so easy
this is bad I'm going in the wrong
direction here
it does take oh and he gets the tactics
foreign
[Music]
yeah I'm actually in some trouble here
it takes the draw wow white is just much
better
yeah God is just a brutal he's so strong
I was definitely better I I don't know
no he's better wow I misevaluated this
totally misevaluated I thought I was
better
oh this is all very accurate Knight
takes A4 is the move here apparently
yeah now what is better Knight F6 is
correct
yeah this very very good play I gotta
this game
yeah but there's an increment so I don't
know why you took a dry it's plus one
it's plus one here
yeah Knight A4 is totally okay Jeffrey
in first
Knight A4 is so inhuman
Knight C5 takes A4
oh and not even B5 Queen B4
okay yeah
and I've missed some crazy ideas
thus far Jeffries in first Jeffrey is
just unbelievable in title Tuesday the
consistency is crazy
oh playing Eric man title Tuesday is
brutal
and we're playing an off stream Eric I
think
foreign
[Music]
good D4
oh he is streaming okay
let's go D3
no Knight E3 makes no sense
foreign
I was not expecting that move
I could suck the exchange but I don't
want to
yeah I totally missed B5
maybe D4 just to go for the chaos
ah what the hell whatever let's go D4
very chaotic move but I think it's the
principled way to play
I mean it's kind of the idea of this
line to push before of course there's
like a pawn sack that's involved here
but I'm going to trust that his his
position is very flimsy I mean his
Knight is undefended this just feels
like it has to be the right move I also
have Bishop F1 related ease okay he took
his time he took
so he goes Bishop B7 I like the look of
Bishop F1
oh but no it doesn't really work
csc4 I blundered yeah
100 C4
okay what do we want to do then maybe D5
no this is not going the right direction
actually
I need some sort of bailout option
which I don't see at the moment
somehow Eric playing very fast
understand how he's pulling this off
yeah I'm just getting crushed
brutal title Tuesday
95 okay d8 and I'm busted
so D4 was a bad call I guess
okay I'm just gonna have to play a pawn
down here
try to hold
foreign
okay let's try this move I guess he has
rookie too
yeah
yeah there's also Bishop takes okay goes
Bishop B4
um I need to think Knight E4 no
[Music]
okay quitting for no
I I can't figure out a move here
oh my gosh
okay let's go here
V6
because Saturday night G5 is interesting
okay age six
no
go back
um crap
no
it's mate
you got him
that was a trick that I saw when I
played Bishop F7
getting Eric let's go
big win
okay six and a half out of eight good
stuff
and he car on six and a half out of it
as well
I might play Hikaru
it's not impossible but it's unlikely
yeah we're very much in the running
there's another break here this next
game is going to be really tough I'm
going to have black against someone
really good
yeah not a great game I've been I've
been really struggling
to get decent positions in this title
Tuesday I'm definitely better here but
these close positions I never really
know how to play
okay G4 apparently is best I played D4
which is not bad
here apparently D5 was best I took and
now I'm worse yeah I missed night before
I thought he had to take my Rook first
yeah now it's like minus plus
57 Bishop E4 is best
Queen D2 is best
Rook F7 best yeah Rook F7 is really
really pretty
sure is best wow okay I found some good
moves Shaq well now I'm worse again
if you had gone Queen D6 I'm much much
worse but Eric blundering the mate
hikara Drew with Jeffrey okay
no it's not time for Friday to go away
we're playing
um
Iranian GM he's former winner of the
World under 18 championship
very strong player
okay I've been winning with a karaoke on
this tournament so let's keep playing it
um
I'm gonna go GF I'm gonna go offbeat
I'm gonna go off a Beat
I've been I've been winning a good
amount of games with this line
let's go Queen C7
Knight t7 and Castle Queen inside and go
for the go from a he does have okay
Queen F3
Castle obviously I'm taking tremendous
risk here and this is very bad
objectively but I'm going to try to mate
him
okay he wants B4 let's go King B8
Bishop H6 okay
yeah my position kind of sucks actually
gonna go Knight F6
five
this is page five maybe
okay wait maybe I should take first
now let's go here
This Guy's super fast
F4 is interesting
or maybe I should take him though I
don't know
oh he's got this move wow what a move
wait Rook G6 is that not trap the bishop
if any can sack his Knight it's unclear
um now let's do it
really
oh Queen G6 oh my gosh I blundered
okay I have to move the Rook then
I mean insane
do we have four Queen G6
you serious
and you saw that and how much time
I guess this guy just doesn't need to
think
foreign
[Music]
right
dude this is insane
I can see why he's
okay wait
[Music]
here
[Music]
okay wait I have some chances now
foreign
foreign
just busted
Queen E3
2 okay wants to trade
I guess I have to
it's got a bunch of puns
[Music]
from G4
maybe here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
oh crap
[Music]
um
oh no
here
[Music]
here
[Music]
we got him oh how did I win that whoa
oh my gosh that was like
getting put through the freaking meat
grinder
my God I'm like my hands are shaking
but if okay now I'm playing baravian I'm
playing for Avian interesting I don't
know how they did those pairings I ah I
guess for Avian already played due to
know it because otherwise it makes no
sense because parabian is the only eight
out of nine and on Drake and he's eight
and a half so
they were supposed to play but it is
what it is we won't I guess we won't get
a car this time
okay so let me try to remember
foreign
ER Bishop C5
number
maybe A5
we can totally beat him
okay castles h4s6
let's go here and try to trade
where I can play H5
you can also go H6 and try to reroute
I didn't want H5 I don't want to weak in
G5 like that
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
let's go here and here
a little bit passive
[Music]
hmm
F4
okay I can Castle
probably I should
I'm still worse but
no some chances here
Knight C5 makes some sense then he goes
Queen F3
yeah
it's actually pretty nasty
maybe A4
I don't know what to do
foreign
if you go through fc1 I guess I'll go A4
try to prevent B3 okay let's play
quickly
try to prevent his beep one from going
up to B3
and I know on Rook B6
King G2 okay let's go Rook B6
foreign
but I have a lot more time
she goes Rook B1
probably go 94 quickly
it was Queen G4 okay wait Knight D3 no I
should go here
well maybe King ain't [ __ ] was better
but anyways
[Music]
where he does
I mean if you have an exchange It's Not
Over
it was Bishop B3
but I have this move
King H3 where's the mate
where's the mate
okay I can just move my Rook perhaps no
I can't oh I can't
there's Rook H4 mate
there's no mate there okay okay
let's go got him
big game
and on Drake it's gonna be nikaru on
Dragon's gonna be the car we're gonna
get on Dragon
I don't see a game that's still going
okay and Drake and yeah
all right here we go
this should be seven and queen B6 I
don't actually know this
okay I could play DC
[Music]
score of q1
we have six
Gwen H5 is interesting
he goes G6 that I'll go Queen E2
and I guess I'll Castle well I don't
love this position
I don't love this position
ship H6 now
let's go here to stop B5
ship C6 maybe or Bishop P3
foreign
I want to take and go Bishop D4 and
cover the dark squares
I'm also setting a little trap if you
play Z5
I'm gonna take C6 and go Bishop H6 and I
think I win a pawn
six he actually wants to
create I will
bite
complicated position I'm probably not
better here but
at least we got some chances
I'm gonna try to go F6 at some point
huh okay don't blunder the bishop here
one thing because E5
point
s
I want to go Bishop E5
foreign
that's the problem
let's go positionally
probably a mistake I should have gone
Bishop F6 oh and I blundered oh my gosh
oh no
yes
ah sorry
yeah I'm just worse obvious the queen G3
no winning chances anymore
oh
it's okay
I was better too no I was not I was
worse
minus plus ear I was sure I was better
in this position but it's just minus
point two
now it's minus one
yeah I was sure I was better at some
point but I didn't see exactly where
foreign
slightly better
slightly better after Knight A5
and now I'm worse Bishop d8 top engine
move Bishop B7 to d8
this maneuver
well I forgot about D4
the funny thing is if not for D4
um I'm better
but again draken is super nice
no it's not to be nice I mean I'm not
lost here
I'm far from Lost here I can defend but
he wins the tournament so why why risk
it
still I'm really happy with the score I
didn't lose a single game I'm gonna get
screwed on the tie breaks as I always do
um so I'm probably gonna get seventh or
eighth or something
because I always get screwed on the tie
breaks
unfortunately
now now it's all about the tie breaks
now it's all about the tie breaks now of
course the ideal result would have been
a draw
oh but then Duda would have caught me
I literally have the worst tie breaks
every time
third
my luck changed
I got third not bad at all paravian
passes me who who am I beat
how does that work isn't there a
head-to-head type break so I beat
ferovian and he passes me anyway
okay that makes sense
um but I got third I'll take it
by half a point
yeah I would have won
um if I beat him draken but
still so I think that's a very good
result it's one of my better results in
the last um couple months
so I'll take the hundred bucks
I think it's 300 or 250 not bad